l'ingérence étrangère un phénomène qui
inquiète de plus en plus au Canada mais
qui a des allures de déjà-vu à l'autre
bout du monde for ninjafirens
en Australie l'influence de la Chine
préoccupe depuis des années et là-bas le
gouvernement a une longueur d'avance
en 2018 le Premier ministre de l'époque
fait adopter des lois plus strictes
résultat les tentatives d'ingérence sont
maintenant passibles d'une peine
d'emprisonnement pouvant aller jusqu'à
20 ans et les lobbyistes des
gouvernements étrangers doivent
s'inscrire à un registre public pourtant
la Chine et l'Australie ont longtemps eu
des relations amicales et des liens
commerciaux importants c'est un scandale
de financement politique qui a changé la
donne et qui a forcé le gouvernement
australien a serrez la vis
il y a eu une transformation en
Australie explique cette expert basé à
Canberra
illeurs mais la loi australienne ne suis
pas parfaite en 2022 les élections en
Australie sont à nouveau assombris par
des soupçons d'ingérence
il y a quelques semaines le patron des
services de renseignement australiens
mettaient en garde contre la menace bien
présente de l'ingérence étrangère
nous avons été un cobaye dans cette
expert australien mais l’ingérence
chinoise n'a pas disparu
mais tout de même mieux que rien selon
ce chercheur canadien
les Australiens ont adopté une ligne
dure rappelle-t-il ils ont fait preuve
de transparence
prendre la menace au sérieux et la
communiquer au canadiens pour éviter de
miner leur confiance envers les
institutions ici Radio-Canada Montréal